زياره منزليه لاقناع كيم بالذهاب الى
بايرن ميونخ نجم يونايتد يرحب بموت
بمشاجره سيده تصبح اول مدربه في تاريخ فرق
انجلترا الرجاليه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من العربيه الرياضه فاهلا بكم
كشف تقرير اخباري يوم الاربعاء
الفني لفريق بايرن ميونخ الالماني لكره
القدم زارا هاري كينج قائده فريقي توتنه
بالانجليزيه والمنتخب الانجليزي في هدف
اقناعه بالانضمام الى بايرن في الصيف
وذكرت صحيفه سبورت بيلد الاسبوعيه في
عددها الصادر اليوم الاربعاء ان تخيل وحسن
صالح اجتمع مع هاري كين في منتصف مايو
الماضي في منزله بالعاصمه البريطانيه لندن
وكان اللاعب معجبا بفكره الانتقال الى
بافاريا عملا بالفوز ببطوله دوري ابطال
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
تلقى الانجليزي ما يسمعون رساله الترحيب
غريبه عقب اتمام انتقاله الى مانشستر
يونايتد الانجليزي خلال فتره الانتقالات
الصيفيه الحاليه اذ اختار البرتغالي برونو
فرنانديز قائد مانشستر يونايتد وسيله
جديده ومبتكره بالترحيب بزميله الجديد
والذي دخل معه في مشاجره عندما كان لاعبا
لتشيلسي خلال مباراه الفريقين في الموسم
الماضي ونشر اللاعب البرتغالي عبر حسابه
الرسمي على موقع انستغرام صورتين من
الشجار الذي وقع بينه وبين اللاعب
الانجليزي مضيفا بعض العبارات الساخره على
سبيل الترحيب ومعلقا لماذا اخذت وقتا
طويلا لتوقع مع تعبير وجه غاضب
تتواصل اولويات نادي فوريست جرين روفرز
الانجليزيه اذ اعلنت تعيين المدربه هاني
دينغلي بشكل مؤقت لتصبح اول امراه تدرب في
تاريخ انجلترا بالدوريات المحترفه للرجال
ومن المقرر ان تكون المباراه الاولى
للنادي المعترف به كالاكثر صداقه للبيئه
في العالم تحت اداره المجرده الجديده وديه
ضد
من المتوقع ان تستمر في تولي مسؤوليه
الفريق حتى قبل انطلاق الموسم الجديد
[موسيقى]